welcome to
the first in person and virtual our
meetup since two years so welcome thank
you everyone for being here in person
i'm very excited to have this hope
everyone in the audience that virtually
can hear this as well i think we are
going this stream's working out all
right great so we have our speaker come
up in just a few moments just show the
normal announcements i always make first
up is always jobs
we've been virtual for two years we
haven't been able to announce jobs from
the stage but who has the job here do
you i think you had a job you wanna come
up here and i will loan you the
microphone awkwardly and you can um
tell us what the jobs right now you
can't go too far for me because there's
actually now you can have those oh cool
thank you
park i hear the cannons roar
um
so my name is ben carlson i'm a senior
software development engineer in test
which is a mouthful at a company called
dv01
where a securitizations reporting
financial technology startup
we're
hiring for three positions that are
looking for our experience
these are all fully remote ex positions
um
we don't offer visa sponsorship but
we're you know we'll hire people in any
location
um
the we also have an optional office in
new york but there's there's absolutely
no requirement or pressure for people to
come in
the roles are a
integrations data analyst and two
data engineers
of these roles the integrations data
analyst is most appropriate for someone
who only has our experience the other
roles also require experience with
additional languages
the company is fantastic we have a lot
of really great benefits um it's a
tremendous corporate culture i've worked
there for four years and i've been very
satisfied
and we're doing some really interesting
work in the securitization space
um if you have additional questions
please reach out to me directly
my email is ben
dvo1.co that's ben
at dv01.co
and you can also see the job postings
which i put in the
slack channel
thank you
great
thank you
let me just get this mic back on me and
folks um my company land analytics we're
hiring we're hiring for an account
executive for like a linux administrator
or linux engineer whatever you want to
call it a data scientist a shiny dev all
sorts of roles we're sort of a small
company so every rule is a hybrid role
you got to do a lot of different stuff
if you want to learn more
landeranalytics.com careers or just find
me anywhere on twitter linkedin slack
anywhere you can find me on meetup
so i'm incredibly incredibly excited to
be back in person and hope everyone
virtually you're excited to be here too
we're gonna have a great talk one of the
things i'm most excited about being back
in person
is
pizza
we gotta actually have pizza together
now
yes so what's easier this is the upside
down slice when you're pizza suprema we
always like to do the the bottom check
right to check the cheese lock and how
it's baked you see this is baked in a
pan an oiled pan before it's baked in a
gas oven
it's been here for a while but has great
cheese lock because the cheese is
actually underneath the sauce it's an
upside down slice so it sticks really
well
so those who have been coming for a long
time might remember we have a poll about
pizza so those of you that are here in
person you'd all take out your phones
and go to bit.lee
pizza pole that's all lower case now
camelcase bitly slash pizza pull and
rank the pizza tell me how it is
you'll see we've been collecting this
data for years there's a two year gap
because
you know we weren't in person but now
that we are we get to start voting again
and
if you go to nyhackar.org
and click on the pizza link you can
actually see a visualization built by
joe marlow showing all the data we've
been collecting over the years and yes
it updates live as people are voting
right now that graph should be getting
up actually might not be getting updated
but the data gets updated live
so you know it's a really cool
experience
so it does so everyone enjoy that folks
in the audience hope you all enjoyed the
pizza folks at home let us know where
you're getting pizza from or other
lesser foods let me know where it's from
if you have pasta empanadas tacos
anything egg rolls whatever you might
have
so that's the pizza hope everyone's
enjoying that and folks coming to us
from home
you're on the youtube channel now there
is the chat functionality so if you want
to ask questions you want to participate
and tell us where you're eating where
you're from what you're eating if you
have questions
ask it either in the youtube channel or
in our slack
if you don't want to ask it on the
youtube channel go to
nyhackguard.slack.com actually be better
off go to nyhackguard.org
and click on the slack link and we will
there's a link there you can join the
slack team once you're in there go to
monthly meetup chat that's monthly
meetup chat and you can ask questions
there of a speaker
at the end of the talk
the audience here in person can ask
questions and anyone ask questions
virtually i will relay those questions
to our speaker
so if you have questions and either
comment on youtube or a meetup
i pull up my list just to make sure i
don't forget anything it's been a long
time since we've done this
so we're very excited to be back here in
person as i said repeatedly because i am
really really excited to see people's
faces
next week is our big annual conference
the new york r conference
if you want to learn more you can go to
rstats.ai
nyr or just rstats.aiworks and there you
can see our speaker lineup you can see
our workshops we have workshops on
wednesday they are mostly full but there
might be like one or two slots left and
we have the conference thursday and
friday so if you'd like to join since
you're part of this meetup right now you
could use code ny hacker 30 for a 30
discount that'll give you 30 discount
off both conference and
workshop tickets
and for those people attending virtually
and in person we're going to do a ticket
giveaway
after the talk is done we're going to
randomly choose a name the people here
in person
will just throw it at you right
the people virtual if you want to win a
ticket since we don't know actually who
is actually watching right now
go into the youtube comments section and
give us your name or go into the slack
channel and give us your name if you
give us your name either in slack or on
youtube you have a chance of winning a
ticket again that's in the ticket's good
for either in person or virtual next
week so you have choices next week if
you're coming to us from far away you
could attend the conference from far
away
we are very excited to have that in
person as well but it'll be nice it's an
in person and virtual and over the past
two years we've gotten really good at
doing the virtual and we're hoping that
we remember how to do the in person it's
a little rusty from now
so a lot to cover today we're back in
person here we're virtual now and
forever we'll always be from now on both
virtual and in person we finally got
that working out well
um
for a while before the pandemic we had
some audio issues but not anymore we got
those fixed we're really really really
excited about that alright
so with that we talked about jobs we
talked about the meetup we have a meetup
next month in july we'll give you more
details later after the conference we
have get conference giveaways we have
conference discount codes we have um
where to ask questions in both youtube
and slack so that's everything right
covered everything oh yeah there's an
art auction and i don't have it on the
screen if you go to rstats.ai slash
auction
i get address right slash auction you'll
see there's an art auction
it's a silent auction done online
and this is for the conference the
auction's open from now until june 10th
around 2 p.m new york time
we have five pieces that were donated
and all the money that is raised through
the auction will be donated to the r
foundation so you get cool r based
artwork
and the money you spend will go to the r
foundation to help keep r going so it's
a win-win-win so go ahead check out
rstats.ai auction to check out our r
auction that was a little almost too
much of a pun but we survived right
so
check that out the proceeds go to a very
good cause i think we can all get behind
and remember folks both this meetup and
the conference
they are both are and friends
for the past 13 years of the meetup in
the past seven years of the conference
we've had r we have python julia go sql
stand c plus plus
all these different languages as long as
they're open source and about data
so
with that i am very excited to bring on
our first both in-person virtual speaker
who's spoken both at the meet up
repeatedly and at the conference
repeatedly and always puts on a good
show
please welcome david robinson to the
stage
[Applause]
i'll trade you thanks so much jared for
the opportunity really excited to be
here so if you're wondering uh what i'm
going to talk about today so am i the
trick today is that i don't know what
data set we're going to be analyzing uh
or what an interactive application we're
going to be creating i asked a friend
michael chao who works at our studio to
aim to send to pick a data set for me
that he thought might make a fun
interactive application and he sent it
to me we're going to open it together
and then uh then i'm going to set it
under an alarm for one hour and in one
hour we're going to see what kind of of
interactive application we can make with
the our uh shiny the our shiny platform
so
i'm going to let's see
i'm going to open the data before i
start before i start the timer so we're
going to but uh
all right here we go
oops see
okay so d rob don't look at this until
the event
title the and go get em and the link is
this and it looks like it's from tidy
tuesday and it must be one that i
haven't uh done yet all right we are
gonna be analyzing dog breeds today so
we're gonna be looking at uh information
dogs breeds data from the american
kennel club uh breed traits trade
description uh breed rank all and i'm
gonna read in it looks like we have
three data sets i am gonna
let's see start the clock for one hour
so
uh first i'm gonna do is just is just
process the data uh
in in our file before we open up shiny
and let's see
tidy versus going to load up i don't
need a little shiny
a few other
things i'm gonna set our theme
theme light
and
jared already mentioned encouraging um
uh interactivity i definitely second
that i'd be really excited to see what
um uh what if people are curious about
things if they've got um i wouldn't go
for questions about the code itself but
especially questions about like could
you do this could we do this could we
graph it this way i'm very excited about
uh that kind of guess so
uh let's look at the the tables we have
first thing i noticed about breed traits
is that it's not tidy
so i'm going to immediately
apply a gather to it where i'll say
gather
into metric value everything except for
breed
and now we've got breed metric and value
okay so that i'm actually exploring that
just a sm a little bit more we'll say
group by metric
summarize oh sorry group by
breed
and metrics summarize uh the average is
the mean of the value and we'll say
and i'll do n-a-r-m equals true
[Music]
let's see
something's
getting an error somewhere
uh
argument is not oh okay value must
include some non-numeric characters okay
let's take a look let's take a look at
the
data and
what did it look like originally
something one of these must have not
been
a number let's see and here we go
code type code length so there's three
columns that i'm going to be removing
which is coat type
coat
length
all right what's that
i could but no uh but but then it would
be um these aren't these aren't uh
categorical the question is could i of
course to a factor i can't pick an app i
don't want to take an average of double
versus smooth because they're not
ordinal
so here i could still say
uh
yeah i've got the uh the breed the
you know i'm gonna adjust for the i'm
gonna just keep the data raw and then
have um because having these separate is
a little bit awkward
um yeah okay
uh so i'm gonna do breed traits gathered
and no i'm gonna actually i'm gonna keep
it i'm gonna keep it separate okay so
the
breed uh
all right um
the negative
let's see what did i
do i forgot
i forgot this
all right
so what do i want to find out from this
table well i mentioned before i want to
find out let's say averages across each
um breed and then how many metrics does
it
have it's grouped just by breed here we
are so we now we can say something like
okay across everything who's the top dog
where the top dog breeds and we have a
couple options but you know like across
everything isn't really that um
uh here i've got 195 breeds and i've got
how many uh traits do i have and that's
really what i'd call it rather than
tradition than
oh boy yeah then uh let's see
uh count trait
we have 14 traits
and
shedding level is negative drooling
level is probably negative barking level
is negative yeah
uh so we got our levels we got
everything okay what i can see is like
we have a lot of data here but it's not
necessarily well suited for aggregation
and that might be why michael picked it
as a um as a good data set for here i'm
going to put this into its own
folder
um open statsmeetup
and here i'm just going to call this
like a prep for data cleaning and we're
going to get
let's see
yeah what's great with this data is i
might yeah i might want to like uh
analyze i might want to look at it by a
particular dog breed who here owns a dog
anybody
zero people okay well my parents have a
um have a cavalier king charles spaniel
let's see if that's in that we're gonna
find out if that's in the data the point
is that we each we might have particular
um
uh data like uh
we might have particular dog breeds that
were interested in others that we're
less interested in so it's a really good
opportunity so for a an interactive
application so we're going to create a
shiny application we're going to call it
dog breeds
and we are going to create the the first
trick i always do with these is i start
by creating a um
i start by creating a single plot that
is uh that is fixed so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to take this uh breed
traits
and i'm going to pick uh just a couple
of of um of dogs for it i'm going to say
let's say we say
filter for breed
is in
is one of let's say
beagles
poodles
bulldogs
and i'm going to filter only for a few
traits does anyone have traits they're
particularly interested in in looking at
i've actually got an idea which is what
if we did um only the ones that are
level like drooling level playfulness
level adaptability level et cetera i
think this is kind of can be kind of
cute to look at these numerically and
then if i put these on a plot i probably
would do something like let's see
boogles let me add let me add one more
what do i do retrievers um uh
rottweilers
okay and then what i'll do is i'll
probably put the bree the value on the
x-axis the breed on the y-axis i am
tired of breed being lower being upper
case so i'm going to breed equals
i'm going to do a rename
and uh
and make this gm call
with faceted wrap by trait
first i want to see is this a good
visualization it's pretty good i don't
mind having them i i don't love that we
have like seven um
uh
graphs here but but i think it's kind of
uh it's kind of interesting one thing i
would might do is make it rather than
alphabetical i might uh
order the traits based on let's see
uh or maybe order the dogs yeah what i
think i'm going to do is i'm going to
say order the breed is fct reorder which
breed is has the highest level as you
mentioned it's not it's not perfect in
terms of like some are positive some are
negative this negative but it's it's a
pretty reasonable kind of a reordering
no this is not i meant to value here we
go
and um
yes and now we can kind of see bulldogs
have the lowest level on average it
looks uh looks like uh and um poodles
are the highest level acro poodle's
highly trainable bull dogs not um
beagles not so much poodles don't shed
well poodles seem pretty great
so the um and
you know though now that i'm looking at
it barking level low for rot while is
that huh maybe we can look up like does
level mean uh the barking level meaning
like they maybe low is better they bark
less
we'll take a look at it isn't maybe what
i expected but we would promise to shine
an interactive application and we've
already spent seven minutes on this prep
so what i'm going to do is um imagine i
actually just ran this by itself nope
imagine i did
hold on uh
oh yeah sidebar panel
make an empty sidebar panel
now just creative that's no good what do
we want what do we want here in the
selector what i probably want is a
couple of them select eyes input
selector's inputs let us choose one or
more uh breeds so i can one or more um
like a categorical variable so i'm going
to pick the breed and say um
breed
the labels breed your choices
are unique
bree um
breed
traits breed
and i'm going to still have some
defaults it's good it's always good to
have defaults in one like this i'm going
to uh say selected
equals this this subset and the key is
then i'm going to change this breed
instead of
now now this data is going to be fed in
it's going to actually say breed in
syntax yup
i use parentheses
here we go so now i've got i can pick
one breed at a time that's not what i
wanted i want uh
i want multi multiple so say multi
equals true
make the screen a little wider
here we go and now i can pick uh anyone
got other dogs they're interested in
which is
dachshund my brother is a dachshund
anyone else
samoyed how do yep there it is all right
and what about a cavalier this one thing
i love about um the auto completely this
is a little autocomplete cavalier
control spaniel that's what my uh
my mother has what does my sister have
it's a there's a word it's a bernie it's
it's a burna doodle i think but uh we
don't have that so we'll put in the the
same
saint bernards all right so here now
we've got a graph we can pick the breeds
and it always shows that on the same
particular like levels they were
comparing it so already we've created an
interactive um app uh application what
else might we um
what else might we want to be
interactive here it is
we're nine and a half minutes in their
first interactive app what else could be
interactive
hey how about the traits i picked those
like like right off the bat but we could
we could have a lot of different of
traits here there's a trick that i like
for this which is that um notice i've
got the select one of these selectize
inputs
it's a pretty common pattern that i want
to say something like select a unique uh
unique item out of this um
uh out of this table so i'm just gonna
say data and column and i'm gonna just
make a uh
let's do dot dot dot
and i'm actually just going to say it's
always unique data
call
and then
we'll do multi true be fixed i'm putting
this it's just a tiny little like um uh
function to split this out where i'm
just going to say okay we take this and
label equals breed breeds
and select it equals these and the key
is that now i can do this with minimal
repeated code i can do the same thing
for traits
and maybe i'll pick a different set i'll
do something like um
uh what kind of what kind of uh traits
were there in the data there
was breed traits
what do i care about well i have um i
have two kids so i want to affectionate
with family
and good with young uh with young
children i don't need it to be good with
with uh dogs and i'm setting defaults
right now other people can set other
things but this is my application so i'm
going to pick the things that i find
appealing i'd care a lot about shedding
level
and uh
yeah that i don't care about the
trainability you know um
these these are these seem like a good
four ones to start with it's often good
to start with something like uh like
ford and i neglected to pass this
all right i need to say um
uh breed traits
breed
and here i say breed traits
trait
there's ways that that can be extend
that kind of pattern can be extended but
the key is that uh i'm finding common
patterns that oh and this hasn't been
hooked up to the back end yet so to hook
up to the back end i'm going to put in
another filter and say trait in input
trait
here we go i can drop playfulness level
and what do people care about if they
were picking a dog you had to pick a dog
tomorrow what do you care about
ruling that does make sense anything
else
uh well the comments i guess on a delay
but
yeah mental stimuli i don't know mental
stimulation needs you don't have to deal
with it i have a cat and a cat is about
the right level of stimulating
simulation i want and you know
adaptability level i live in an
apartment hope it's adaptable so the um
so
yeah we can add them we can remove them
let's do a bit of testing here what
happens if i remove all traits uh that's
no good the way that i can
fix that is say require input
trait this req trick says now if i drop
all the traits it just is blank it's not
going to like uh give an error an ugly
error message or anything like that cool
so we've got now got this tool that can
um that can explore
uh
two dimensions of this data and again
it's really handy because they're not um
the mentions of the state they're not uh
natural it's not natural to aggregate
them and that's when interactivity
really comes into play is um
it's yeah it's not it's not natural
when it's not natural to just to just
take all this data in and um and collect
it and collect it up into a summary so
i'm going to do just a little bit of
cleaning up i'm going to say i don't
think we need an x or y axis at all and
i also wonder do we have any caption
like information trade information from
um
wide format uh no it's not a oh let's
see
you know i don't really um
i don't i'm not seeing a lot of data
that needs to be like carried along oh
except i've got this
trait
long description okay we're gonna we're
gonna bring this we're gonna bring this
in for sure uh
for starters i'm going to i'm just going
to
reload this and
yeah okay uh
like i said i don't feel like i needed
an xy axis
but i might be interested in the trade
descriptions
so
what the um
uh
yeah let's take let's take a look at the
second at the second table then in our
in our prep where which is the
trade description we have one row for
each trait i like that it has a um
i like that it has a description i like
that we can actually join this in
i'm going to turn the columns lowercase
there's a function janitor clean names
that i tend to use for that and other
than that i'm going to say let's see
notice each of them has like low to high
oh and this can actually tell us things
like what i was wondering about before
about the drooling does or about the
barking does high level mean more
barking only to alert very vocal uh all
right so the um
yeah this is pretty this is pretty handy
why why do we think this handy because
this information that might be useful
when you're looking at a set of traits
and uh how but how we're gonna display
it uh to the to the user well here's an
idea what if under this um
what if uh
let's see
where my uh uh
what if underneath here we actually had
a table that would tell us like what a a
description of what each of these mean i
think that might be kind of handy so
what i'm going to do is create another
output called description uh output
trait descriptions
and this one will be a render table
and i'll take the breed traits
i'll it will also require
a trait of the trade column and i'll say
filter for
same thing the other one filters for
and actually and let's just select the
trait
and the description
didn't work oh because i didn't put it
into the into the ui so now let's go up
to the ui and say we've got a plot up
nope i'm going to put it in the sidebar
because why not i'll put a plot what is
it a table
output
and then what did i call it i called it
trait descriptions
um
[Music]
see
it didn't it didn't love that i wonder
if it didn't um
you know i wonder if it doesn't like
putting an output in the in the sidebar
let's see what happens if i put it over
here
nope
something is something oh there it is
description doesn't exist what did this
call it
it was called trade description
it was i think it was called oh boy i
didn't even yeah yep
i did not even uh
here we go
look at that now i've got like a
description of the um of the trade in
here you know i actually i used i was
thinking of putting it in here but um
uh i was going to put it in here but i
kind of like it down here because it
looks like a lot of text
uh and yeah there's kind of given
information about each of these given
alphabetical order which is the same
order as we have above
uh
yeah i kind of like that i kind of like
this some uh this is an output
what would what could i do to maybe make
it a little less
um
[Music]
a little less ugly well the um
think about what i can put it can i put
this in some kind of box i think i can
do something like let's see put the
output in a
uh huh
can you do subtitles in table outputs
oh we know a subtitle in the in in here
oh i think that's gonna be long i don't
know it might be crowded what i was
thinking of putting in here is this zero
one to five we say what does a one mean
what does a five mean like if i can get
if i can fit that in the plot that might
be pretty uh pretty nifty uh
but yeah i was gonna start with um with
the table
and
i think there's a there's a thing i
could do i can say create a box it's
actually been a little bit of time uh
shiny
oh no it's that that's in um
what do you call it that's
in uh
see
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
forget what i forgot how i might put
make this a little bit prettier but you
know it works for me now and um there's
other things that we can organize
here we go oops
let's do that um what do you say we do
that one to five things so now i've got
this um the traits my graph the
descriptions uh let's try getting the
like into here what does um
what does a one mean what does a five
mean i'm kind of visualizing a world
where we have something like the um
sideways text at one and sideways text
at five that says here's what each of
these um
these traits mean
so let's
try creating that in in the trade plot
so
what i do in these situations is
sometimes i'll i'll create a fake input
we'll just say uh the the breed is um is
going to be i know beagles and the trait
is going to be
loyalty
was that was loyal to even one i'll say
barking level
and now i can run this just like to take
a quick look at
it
now the key is that i can um
actually now do a level that says geom
text aes label
equals and what it was it called was
called trait
1
and put it at a x
of 1
and the key is give it a different data
set so say data equals trait description
no it's a and a y of
1 as well okay
a comma
oops uh
let me test it first
i need let me see what is it
i thought input was smaller than this
so i'm trying out like this i just want
to graph these two oh i wanted this
filter this trade description
filter trait
is
this an input trait
here so now actually what i've got is
like a um
i've got some text on it it doesn't look
great but i can just rotate it and i
don't remember how does anyone know how
to rotate text 90 degrees
in a plot
i need to annotate yeah
if i said angle equals 90 do we think
that works
i'm going to find out
yeah that seems to work but actually i
probably want to spin it around and put
a 270 i think that looks a little bit
better
and then uh
i'm going to put
i'm going to put it in the color uh make
the color be
i don't know
and
yeah what i'm going to say what i'm
going to do is i'm going to put it at
however many um
breeds there are
unique input breed
divided by two
and
[Music]
i meant to end distinct breed and now
i'm just trying to get this text there
we go it's like yeah you know it doesn't
look absolutely incredible but
what uh what might make it look a little
better to change this to a geom label
which puts a little box around it oh it
does but it doesn't care for the angle
i'm going to leave it as it is i'm going
to leave it as it is
gm text and the last the and then i just
need to
also have the um
it's a lot of copy paste i'm about to do
but also have this at five
we could pull it we could uh picks it
out pull it out we're um oh and it'll be
trait five can pull it on a function you
know it's like
only when you want to be non-stop
you know how do people i don't love it i
don't know it was an idea it was an idea
that i spent
uh uh whatever already spent about six
minutes on this this idea i'm not crazy
but i'm gonna hold on to it just in case
but the key is that um that would be a
way we could try bringing this in i
think there are we um i think there are
other ways we could i just put this at
the end of the file commented out and
all right and so yeah so right now we
have is our breeds traits etc any ideas
what we could do next
what's that
yeah i think you're right i think it
should let's do um
here we go uh
i can say x so uh
it's [ __ ] cauli
to start at zero but we can i think i
think you're right and we should do x
slim
one to five because one is uh like one
is oop it doesn't like that one bit uh
so what i'll actually do is code
cartesian
and say um excellent equals so carol
cartesian means cut off even if
something goes beyond the edge of it yes
this is a little bit more like it uh
i like this that actually probably would
have even made the text look better but
i'm still not going to put it back all
right
this is us looking at um at uh
breeds and traits at the same time
let me say we go to the other data set
see what the other one is yeah
cool
we had the um the other one was breed
rank all
oop
i already used trade description and the
traits data so these are oh look at this
this is by year all right so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to gather the
um everything except i'm going to gather
everything except for breed
and
links and
image
oh great there's going to be images okay
so that that's the thing we can um uh we
can do
i'm going to gather these into year
and uh value
or rank really
i'm also not notice year is gonna be
like 2013
it's going to be it's going to be text
not on an actual year so i need a little
bit more cleaning i'm going to do
parse number we'll pull out
whatever ye whatever numbers in the in
the um the year column and now we got
now we've got the year back and we've
got breed we've got rank uh so uh what
years is it over it looked like 2013 to
19.
so yeah no to 2020. all right so that
could make a good uh
uh bar plot we could start a part of me
on a line plot we could start asking for
something like uh filter for breed is um
is poodles
and i am gonna do
after the gather janitor clean names
turn it lowercase and now i've got my
poodles we can do something like okay
let's plot
the rank by year
what is like yeah best dog
who says
that feels unfair and we've got to rank
uh just the poodles so this tells me we
can create a plot over time and that uh
sometimes the point about that is it's
going to be totally different from
everything we've been looking at so far
it's not going to be uh it's going to be
in
we could create a whole new application
what i'd rather do is create tabs as we
say let's um let's have a tab uh
tab set here we can have one tab for uh
by trait and one for over time
uh i think it's gonna be a way we can um
we can create interactive visualizes
with this sound good to folks
cool
so there's some virtual requests as well
oh yeah that's actually this is yeah i'd
love to hear any uh requests and then
we'll
vote on them or something yeah
i'm gonna repeat i'm gonna repeat the
request that we're hearing um
it's like the best dogs uh by each trait
all right i like this oh sorry the the
suggestion was rank dogs based on user
selected traits
so like best dogs
in trait
grape what else
a tooltip
time series of rankings yeah so that was
the one that i was planning on doing uh
i'll start saying i don't know how to do
this so we could find out together but
i'd love to end with that uh the tooltip
would have so the idea was a tooltip
when hovering over fast at title with
description
i love it and i want yeah i said i want
to i want to wait on it because i
because i need to learn how to do that
how to do that
this these two i know how to do i'd love
to do i'd love to start with time series
because it's a new kind of uh
visualization but i think we can do both
of these in two different tabs like have
a tab for
over time and have a tab for best breeds
sound good
all right
so we're going to do is change up our
our setup a little bit so that we i'm
going to keep the same sidebar panel but
we're just going to come back later i
think because susie because some of
these inputs are relevant for
some panels and others aren't uh what
i'm going to do is a
tab set panel here there we go
and here i've got a tab so then and then
the tab set panel has
uh
i'm also remembering what is the o it's
a first argument no no i'm wrong uh it's
tab i'm quickly reminding myself
tab panel has a yup okay so first we're
going to have um
uh
uh by uh breed
trait explorer was that first one that
we were trying out and it's a plot
output
of um
just that the actually you know it was a
combination of the
it was uh two things the plot output of
the trade plot
and it was a table output
of the
trait descriptions
which i'm going to come back to whether
we want to share some of this logic
between the tabs the second is we're
going to do over time
i'm going to put this as the leftmost
panel for now not because we want to
keep it there because it'll be better
for um for debugging and we'll say
over
over time plot
and i'm going to create an uh
yes we've got time and overtime plot all
right so i've got trade descriptions
trade plot i'm going to set up a new one
that is output
over time plot render plot
and it's gonna this one's gonna be the
what do we call we called it the breed
rank it was called breed rank
breed rank all
i'm going to give i'm going to clean
this up and give it a new name which is
rank over time
this is the table that i wanted to work
with
yeah
we do the cleaning in advance that here
i can do rank over time and i apply a
similar filter to what we did before
we'll just say filter breed in
input breed
and then
plot the year rank
uh gm line i'm going to expand the
limits to be uh the rank should always
include
zero uh one
uh sorry the the that is the y-axis
include one i'm also gonna say i'm gonna
say
say uh well i'll show what this looks
like for one
dog is now it looks like they're getting
better but this beagle is actually
getting worse
because the rank's getting higher so
no good i actually want to say scale y
reverse and now we've flipped it so we
can say okay this this used to be in the
fourth place now it's going backward i
think there's a name for this uh which
is a um called a subway plot and we're
going to see why once we had a couple of
breeds
in a subway plot it's customary to add
points
and oh boy wow this this this messed up
good the uh look at look at how this
looks so the plot looks fine but the
ranks look uh look funky the um uh huh
uh why sorry sorry the it is the the it
it kind of spread out from here what
happened over oh boy yep what did i do i
put
tab panel tab set panel what did i do
what did i do oh because i put it in the
the sidebar so the challenge that i did
is i'd never put in a
uh
sidebar layout
main
panel
here we go so now i've got the um now
i've got overtime and we can see okay
beagles bulldogs bulldogs uh poodles
rottweilers uh notice that they're not
exactly in in inappropriate order so
that's something i might want to do in
advance is let's reorder the um
in my rank over time let's do uh breed
equals fct reorder
uh breed by rank
oops
and i'll do it by the average
so see now bulldogs beagles poodles
rottweilers it lines up it's a little
bit easier to read
uh something else that we that what else
what could i do with this well i don't
like that it's some so let's just test
this out if i try adding a couple of
dogs
it's a lot of dogs so some breeds don't
pop up ah okay that that's actually
that's super interesting is some breeds
are in one data set but not the other
one we're gonna fix that and that's
actually fun because it's going to be a
little bit um it's going to be a little
bit fancier how we have to fix that one
but the um so i'm going to add that as
another note of to do is um is reactive
reactive sidebar
uh panel based on number of breeds
that's our base on tab
selected
uh all right the um
but yeah other than that what would
people do to make this look to make this
uh look better
yeah i got it you know i gotta say like
i'm not um
i think we can get rid of the of the x
and y axes
or at least put a capital y year
yeah i can just capitalize them into
that they look fine the um
i don't i don't need to put uh color
access sunlight uh
i don't need anything on color
legend yeah so i've got both of these
okay and i see how they differ over time
uh
thinking about it now it's yeah i really
no
not my this is this is good uh okay
so
so
uh
what if i want to make this interactive
what if i want to be able to mouse over
and see things on on the data there's
something really really powerful for
this which is the um
here we go i uh which is ggplotly so
ggplotly basically i get for free
the plotly package which um
by for free i mean with i don't mean for
no money i mean for very little effort i
can actually just do um
i can just get library plotly and say
here i've got my overtime plot i'm going
to name it g it's the plot and i'll say
plotly
output
g
and suddenly the graph is interactive
here we go if we up nope you know why
because i need to say render plot lee
and i need to say up here plot lee
output for the overtime plot
mm-hmm
the one i was supposed to use here was
ggplotly
here we go
why well here i just uh now i can mouse
over at see particular data points uh i
think it adds a little bit and there's
something i like about it oh one thing i
like about this is that i can actually
add or remove them on the sidebar
not as necessary since we already have
this ad removed but it's nice that it
comes with the um the package
all right any other thoughts for uh this
yes
oh man
all right sorry cow plot
so image is the dog on the on the oh on
on the access
oh so for the breed trade explorer oh
man yeah okay all right that's an idea
any any other ideas so sorry so the idea
is so one idea i've already checked off
the time series of rankings uh we'll do
uh images of the dog on the axis all
right
there's a package called headliner yeah
for and um can you repeat
repeat that line
headline uh so if i do library headliner
so this this is somebody who's making a
plug for their package where where we
say um
uh
oh okay so this will say did this oh
okay i see so it can say something like
um it'll turn it'll turn this plot
or this data into um
two data points uh into talking points
i like this okay so what do i like about
this i like that it um that what i what
i would do with this is take this breed
rank all
i would um
bleed rank sorry i'd take the cleaned
version
group by breed
i'd summarize for earliest is first of
um of rank and latest
is last of rank
and now it sounds like what a headline
can do
is say
uh let's see uh head so i'll say
uh headline equals headline of for of
earliest latest
uh huh no it wants um
it doesn't love this let's see given two
values
see a headline
so i can do one of these
that seemed to work
why is this yeah so i would have
expected this step
to work where it says but it says index
one must be a character numeric effect
or not not a list i would have thought
that earliest
and latest being numeric would have
worked for oh it does
but somehow oh
did it get does it maybe not work with
large data
or does it not lower if one of them was
n a
something was in a all right somebody's
got a got a bug to fix in their package
where it can't handle is it a difficult
error message when um when there's
there's missing data
so
uh
why would we use this because we can now
say let's filter for one breed
is poodles
and it'll say increase of two like eight
versus six uh it'll say the um versus
like no change etc
um i think this is uh i i think this is
cool because i can say i could just um i
could take
uh
i could have a one called a chain go
called
over
overall changes
and
i'll just uh i'll call it headlines
okay so this is the head on the headline
package
all right so i'm going to say headlines
and now i can pick
in my app i'm going to actually add a
table of headlines so under this rank
remember how the table earlier of trade
descriptions well i'm not going to use
that again what i'm going to do is say
output
headline table
is going to be render
table
headlines
filter breed in
input
breed
and i didn't put it i didn't put the
result anywhere i'll throw into after
the um
the oh after here in the overtime i'll
say table output
and i only want i don't want the
earliest and late what i saw were there
was where i had earliest and latest
columns
so we say okay the bull headline
bulldogs there was a difference beagles
decrease if poodles increase of of one
nine versus eight so we we have just one
other way that we could try um uh
turning these into headlines i think
that that's neat i would probably want
to customize i'm not gonna go about it
right now but that would want to
customize for something like the
decrease action of three actually means
improved by uh so the um
so see that uh that's that's the trick
is i'd actually want to change the um
uh the trend phrases
you know i bet i can i can customize
this and just say trend terms more less
no difference here we go i'm going to
customize this one where i'll say
trend
phrases are
more
is
is decree um declined
less equals improvement
improved
no improve
mint
and uh same equals no difference
it's needed it's in these little
automated um uh chain uh
there was no do ah i probably wanted no
difference improvement of three decline
of two decline of one this makes it a
little clear what the the description is
all right i think it's it's not all that
necessary on top of this but hey i
learned to use it use a new trick today
so thank you now the um
jared did i miss one of the suggestions
yes i really want to do that yeah
i did um
oh no i didn't do mouse over the um i
didn't do mouse over the the facet
labels but i do want it let me see where
uh
what do you um most just in terms of the
the
oh ranking dogs based on user selected
traits i really do want to i really
wouldn't want to do a best dog um and i
think it'll be it'll be uh pretty quick
so let's throw let's throw it in i'm
gonna throw in a third tab
we have two tabs so far
over time retreat explorer
and i'm
messing with the order and
best
breeds
so just like that i'm adding one more
and we're doing
output
best breed plot render
up just a plot not a not plotly i think
it's going to actually be very similar
to the other one we did and that it is
it's going to filter based on trait to
this this other one we did on
on by on all the dogs by trade except
that this time it's going to say filter
for these traits
top n
and the and the highest let's start by
we we pick it ourselves we say top 10
uh by
value
and then we fat was still faster wrapped
by trait
and
most of this is still the same
um
ah the trouble is
the trouble is now that i'm seeing it
uh this is like this is best buy barking
level for example and there is there
just might be too many fives in data
like this yeah like
i feel like best trait is there's almost
always going to be a couple fives let's
actually find that out where if i say
something like filter for value is
five
count breed
i actually meant to count trait
yeah there's only a few that wouldn't be
filled up with fives all right i like
the idea but it's a bit but uh looks
like i won't um
saying i want to pick the traits uh
won't quite work out that's probably
where i should have started
any other suggestions from inside the
room before i move on to one of the one
of the group one of the internet
suggestions
just remind ourselves here's what the
visualization looks like right now
all right what do we got from the
internet
all right a tab with facets of b swarms
across a set of traits showing all dogs
and make look hotly to allow
highlighting of one dog or
i gotcha and uh
okay so i guess on the x and the y will
be two traits
uh
yeah uh all right the excellent would be
two traits and one thing that means is i
uh and then every breed will be on it
that means i'm not gonna be picking
i'm definitely not gonna be picking
breeds but uh i will leave in the breeds
trait selector for now i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna create a whole new sidebar but
i might need additional um uh axes okay
yeah so what i'm going to all right i
like this idea we've got 15 minutes left
we're going to do is um is trait versus
trait uh trait
uh straight scatter plot
uh yep yeah so beast one will be because
so many are at these exact values uh
output scatter
that um
uh that it'll needs we'll need some uh
some jitter in here here we go
uh what did i call it i called it a
trait scatter plot
render
plotly so let's create this plot first
what we're going to do is we're going to
breed traits
and filter for we're going to need to
pick yeah i'm going to pick just two and
this time then we'll
so we'll say trait
in uh let's say
barking level and uh
what was it uh oh it was fat what was it
faceted by
within according to that
in the suggestion
yeah sure
uh so i'm gonna it could be in the
meantime but i think it might be but
we'll see
uh let's see so
uh tab with facets of b storms across a
set of traits showing all dogs oh um
highlighting of one dog and one
facet and oh i um i get what it was
going for here i'm not
oh yeah
all right b swarms across
i think i think i didn't know what to be
swarmed is but that's okay i'm gonna do
i'm gonna um
i'm gonna uh
make what i was thinking of
uh which is all right i know what i
think of which is a scatter plot of um
of trade versus trait
so barking let's say barking level
versus drooling level
and uh
[Music]
and do geom now we might notice if we do
geom point this is super boring because
they're all um they're all just like one
to one to one but if i do geom jitter i
can compare uh look at two traits at
once uh because geom jitter adds a
little bit of noise that was too much
noise i'm gonna say height is 0.5 with
this 0.5
that was way too much 0.1 0.1
here and that was too little and now we
can say okay now you see i've got like
uh i can i can pick ones in a particular
uh area and by making it a
g
plotly i can also add a um
let's see i can do
label is not is kind of a fake level
we're basically gonna allow me to mount
to mouse over it
so i could say uh
there we go
plotly output
uh trades uh
plot the output of i'm sorry
gigi plotly of g
and
i need to add a let me see i had a tab
for trade versus trade but you might
have noticed that i haven't um
i haven't made these interactive yet but
the key is they can say okay i can look
at all of these
i don't quite remember how to customize
the tool tip but that would be kind of
the next step is i just want the tool to
be the breed nothing else
but here i can say okay i want barking
level five drooling
and i actually noticed that yeah the
ones that have barking level five a very
low drool oh man that's a bummer but
there's one that is let's see uh i guess
because like
doesn't uh i guess there are a few that
don't drool and don't bark plot hounds
those are the dog to get if you hate
both barking and drooling i didn't know
you could be zero i guess uh that might
be
i bet i bet it's some but i don't know
maybe it's here maybe it's a maybe it's
just a maybe it's uh it's some other
kind of bug uh
what's that
uh
yeah so the um so i'm going to throw in
a filter over here i'm just going to say
value greater than zero i i don't i
don't like um
i don't like
that zero in there so um
here yeah we can look at our like
pecans things like that i can compare
two traits but here what i really want
is um i want to be able to select those
two traits and use them like dynamically
i want to be able to compare the two
particular traits that i'm interested in
i'm going to add two other selectors
here this one's not a multi-select it's
a single select
so i am going to
do the same kind of select
uh
i could refactor this out but we've only
got we've got 10 minutes left
and i really want to win that car
so i'm going to add a um let's see
single select
uh and then this one's going to be
x uh
trade x
drooling level
trait
y-axis barking level i'm i'm uh
transposing it from the last time that i
had the defaults from the last time but
the key is that i've got my trait x and
y axis
single selectors and now i need to use
the trade x and trait y
uh and i've got to uh
go
and yeah instead of um
there's a simple trick for this i can
use this with tidy eval but one of the
simplest tricks i can do is called aes
string it's mo it's mostly not
recommended these days because um
there are other approaches but honestly
it just makes things so easy i just say
trade out of the y
and put the breed in and now it's just
going to treat those uh if all goes well
i can just pick these two traits nope
all did not go well and widen up didn't
this go well because let me see i
picked these oh i know what happened
yep none of this this thing that i was
doing isn't going to work the um the
select as input with these choices uh
because tradex it's looking for a tradex
column that wasn't that wasn't great
that wasn't so smart of me uh that's all
right what i'm going to do is instead do
here we go i'm going to say
tradex
and
type object type close oh data needs to
be breed traits
and
who has got an object of closure closure
is not subsettable before
i feel like i get it that every day
breed traits here we go so i have a
tradex
selected some um oh
one moment
there we go uh-huh nope i do not the
trouble is that it doesn't escape the um
the names when i put it in his aes
string and that's no that's not good so
what i'm going to do is aas
there's a trick to this
which i just need to remember on uh in
a hurry which is something like
if tradex is a drooling
level
there we go
all right and
i think that this is the approach in
tide eval but we're going to find out
because it's been a while since i used
this
there we go so we can say drool what it
was bang bang with the acceleration
point explosion sim and the key is up it
didn't up
nope oh i see what happened the um i
have a filter here which is which is not
it's actually not necessary at all now
that i think of it
and here we go now you can pick the two
most important
uh uh things that you care about in a
dog and comp and compare them and see
okay here's our anatolian shepherd dog
not at all affection not at all
trainable if that's what you're looking
for that's that's the one but here are
your affectionate trainable dogs up here
uh so picking two
uh comparing two traits all right i
didn't get to the let me see um i have
six minutes left what i actually want to
do is make this panel cond i actually
don't want this tip here um these trade
x and y axis unless i'm on this tab it's
it's pretty ugly if it uh if it does it
should only appear in fact the other one
shouldn't even appear in this tab so
we're gonna do is remind ourselves
conditional panel on tab set i have six
minutes to solve um to solve a thing
that i do not remember how to do so
we're gonna um
[Music]
oh boy no answers to uh no answers on
this one
tab set
panel
conditional
panel
uh is the one i was just looking at
really thought conditional panels oh
yeah here it is okay
input dot now where does remember the
string select tabs all right
nope
this is not a tab set panel
see this is what i'm looking for is a
page of side this exactly let me change
the sidebar elements
input a tab selected
uh-huh okay
okay this is what i was looking for is i
need this uh what i need to do is they
say tab set panel
id
equals tab selected sure
and then we put the conditional we put
the other um
part the parts that we only we only we
want conditional to be in a conditional
panel if the tab if input tab selected
equals three
three being this one you know we you
know it uh the bummer is it's not it's
just not showing up right here so this
condition isn't working is this error
related
nope that's from an earlier iteration
input.tab see i really thought this was
going to work is this in the tab set
panel
let's see
tabs oh i see we got these value equals
here
hmm
i don't know why it uh needs it would
need value i would just wouldn't use
something like title but we're going to
find out together if this works fingers
crossed aha there we go we did is we now
have a conditional panel that only
appears on this one and what i actually
like about this is we actually don't
need the
trait selector for this one so i'm
actually going to going to put i'm going
to put everything in there conditional
paddles when appropriate what i'm going
to do is conditional panel
and say condition
is 2
look at
nope is not equal to 2 is what i wanted
actually only when it's equal to one
god i'm good
all right and that
we have three minutes left let's um so
this was the um
this is our interactive graph i don't
think i can add additional features i
can't add the images that's too bad but
one thing we can find out is am i able
to publish
uh this wouldn't that be something if we
can actually put this online in the last
three minutes that we have i actually i
haven't tested it it would have been
smart to test it uh before i before i
came here and see if we've got um i
forgot the ability to put to actually
put this online uh but the uh
go
it used to be i used to really have this
set up where you could up you gotta
connect i have one of these accounts
don't i
well that's a bummer i might just uh
yeah i'm gonna run out i'm not gonna be
able to um uh to put it online uh
right now but
all right any anything we think we can
do in two minutes
two minutes left
the bug i thought that bug would take
longer to fix than it did
what's that
bridge no no it's um oh yeah creature
going oh no yes all right you gave us me
something to do
yes
everyone knows you only need 58 minutes
to make an application i don't know what
i was thinking what i was thinking
asking for a whole hour but the um but
yes this is
here we go and uh
it's only on it's
only on the first one or the second one
right
yeah not equal to three
that's pretty good
all right
then we got our minute half spare any
questions
[Applause]
i already have a few virtual questions
that came in cool so we'll but you did
you there
oh so so yeah jared just said he's going
to do the um the giveaway i'll tell you
to announce
what you you and out the names
i'll give you the name all right
okay
um is nicole over here i i saw the name
we picked for the in person name i don't
know if we have the virtual name
all right nicole stepped out all right
our our winner for the in-person folks
we're gonna do
one giveaway for in person one giveaway
for virtual so well and the winner a
winner from the room or winner from
virtual and they can use it for whatever
type of ticket they like a virtual
ticket or in-person ticket so from
inside the room the winner the free
ticket is emily levitt
emily congratulations
so you're going to talk to nicole she
will give you information for your free
ticket to the conference
um nicole that's our in-person ticket i
didn't see who we are giving it to for
the virtual ticket
hold on folks
luca valenegri
congratulations luca valdegri let's go
in round of applause
[Applause]
so luca you are going to message um
nicole on slack you can find her on the
the ny hacker slack and give her your
information and then she'll give you the
information you need to get a free
either in-person or a virtual ticket
this is your phone
um
then folks
uh just reminder for those of you that
didn't win a ticket since you're here
tonight virtually or in person you can
use code ny hacker 30 for a 30
discount on the tickets so go ahead and
get your tickets now uh we are going to
be closing ticket sales soon we're
actually trying to keep capacity to be a
little we're we're keeping capacity for
social distancing basically
so we are close to being at our ideal
capacity so we are going to cut the
tickets off soon so you know buy it
sooner than later so we have to be like
oh sorry it's too late because we are
trying to keep it safe for people who
don't feel comfortable being packed on
top of each other those of you who used
to the
our conference from years past you know
that we overstuffed the room full of
people it was more people than should be
in there we're doing the complete
opposite this year we're gonna have far
fewer than the room holds just to make
sure everyone feels comfortable
so with that we have our two giveaways
congratulations to the two winners emily
and luca it was emily right emily and
luca congratulations we're gonna have
some audience questions so first i will
ask a virtual question just get the room
going then we'll see that any questions
inside the room will go back and forth
between in the room and personal for
that though you need to come get the mic
back on because they're asking you the
questions
yep and i'll repeat them
and we will have two mics next time
folks
ah oh i totally forgot to oh so the
question is what is my favorite shiny
theme i forgot to um to pick a theme a
theme today uh but the the trick of
shiny themes is i can do shiny themes
and here's something really fun i can go
anywhere in the app and throw in a um i
think it's called a theme what is it
select theme explorer
shiny i can't remember what it's called
called shiny themes
theme selector
and watch this we can do um i actually
now get a box so i can try out different
themes like cerulean or you know um
space lab and uh yeah different fonts
and stuff you know i told myself i was
going to try out a non-default theme
because the default theme is only okay
my favorite is uh cosmo or wait was it
yes i think my yes my favorite is cosmo
like the fond lunchy everything oh no no
wait hold on it was
no i'm trying to remember what it would
have what
there was one particular one it had a
kind of a darker bar at the top
well i don't remember
his last name
uh
well i don't remember what my what uh
the one i liked was
but
oh i remember why it's different it has
a different color for the nav bar than
the tab bar uh but yeah but once i
picked the uh which i liked but i do
yeah i like cosmo and this and the way
to pick it would be i think i'm trying
to remember exactly where it goes i
think it goes
uh
fluid
i'm not i i think those theme is shiny
themes
shiny theme
i think it goes there and then i can get
rid of the
selector
yeah so now that now is just set
questions in the room
all right maybe another virtual question
will get the audience
how would you make this mobile friendly
and make it work between portrait and
landscape mostly i would so the question
is how do you make this mobile friendly
and work between portrait and landscape
the answer is mostly i wouldn't
the um i i actually don't know that much
about um about reactive applications in
uh in shiny i would love to publish this
and then find out how it does on a phone
and if there are ways to improve it it's
that's a good question i don't know
about that
anyone in the room enough questions well
keep asking every time there we go so in
my workplace the biggest
barriers to
adopting shiny dashboards in any sort of
production-based capacity is
authentication and state persistence
what are your go-to solutions
yeah so the question is the biggest
challenges um at the first question of
the workplace are authentication and
state persistence in terms of using
these in a production capacity so one
question is when you meet when you say
capacity production do you mean within
the company or external to the company
with the company okay so i'm going to
start with persistence because that i
know a lot more about without a question
the way to approach persistence in shiny
applications is the pins package so i
didn't use it today but the pins package
is a way to
cache a um take an r object stick it
somewhere and
pin it somewhere and fetch it back later
and the great thing about it is it's
flexible in terms of where it's um it's
pinned so you can do
uh so so the pins package there we go i
can say pin read or pin write the same
way that i would like read or write a an
object but the most important thing is
that it can come from a variety of
different types of boards so the pin
read would be into a particular board
but it could be a folder on my computer
but it could also be a um it could also
be a board in
microsoft azure it could be aws s3 uh it
could be google cloud it could be on on
github and the point is that it um it
provided wraps all the stuff in uh
involved in
sticking something there versioning it
and then getting it back so i previously
worked at a shiny application that had
uh that was based on on metrics that
updated every day and it was much faster
to have it it loaded the pin at the
exact moment the graph was being viewed
rather than load all of them at once
that meant it could have hundreds of
metrics uh sending
it can also persist data like you you
persist data from the um
from the application back in uh back
into a pin the key is that it is that
it's a little clumsy because you're
always working with our objects instead
of say like a database relational model
so i'd say there are such there are some
circumstances where it's where pins
works great we really want to be like
there's situations where maybe you want
more persistent like creating new
objects to create deleting those objects
modifying those objects where pins might
not be perfect but it's some it's
definitely worth checking out
authentication the only the only uh area
i know is like shiny server pro which
maybe you're already using
and oh and uh
jared also called out connect so there's
there's enterprise versions that are
that are um
i uh my understanding is they're
definitely worth the money if you have a
large number of people using them
internally i don't
have the need for them internally right
now i've never needed a shiny
application with a consumer wasn't
somebody run actually running it but
uh
yeah
i'm sure the other studio sales folks
would love to talk to you
any other questions
so we have time for one more virtual one
more in person uh do you use promises
uh promises uh
that's like the like the future like the
sort of
percent dot dot dot angle
oh no no i don't i i haven't used
promises when i um when i'm working with
reactive data in
uh shiny something i haven't i didn't
show here but we we use the same data in
a couple of the same uh pattern in a
couple places like trait description and
filter i could have done here like
filtered traits
and up here said filtered
i could have used react what i do use is
um
the reactive
wrapper in shiny
which is a little similar in that uh
this is this is now not exact not
exactly an object it's it's something
that um it will update once and then
everything that uses it downstream can
uh can use this uh but no i haven't yeah
i haven't used promises much
anything else in person
i think we're great
sure
at what point do you start
introducing modules
yes the question is at what point do you
start introducing modules into your
shiny apps so a module is a really
useful way to to um take a common ui
pattern that on both the server side and
the um and
the ui side
and abstract it out uh it's um
uh there's two i think two of that
values to it one is that as your
application gets larger you're gonna
you're gonna wanna split out um these
tabs into separate files uh and in the
process you're going to run the
situations where you have the same input
or output name uh in different um in
different places and then it starts to
get um then you'll you'll get confusing
errors so shiny like
uh
when the application got really large
this was in total what 134 lines of code
i think it's not um it's very manageable
but if you're running an entire
application you can get a lot larger so
the first would be like just to organize
your code in uh
into sections modules are effective for
that much more important i think though
is is abstracting away general patterns
and tools that um that can be that uh
can be used across many um
uh they can be used across many
different like like have basically have
uh things built on top of shiny that
other people can build applications in i
actually think that we've really under
invested in i think there's a lot of
exciting things happening in interactive
visualization like uh plotly and such
but i think we've under-invested in
shiny modules as packages i think
there's uh there's in terms of ways of
organizing entire like entire pa like
pages around particular like data sets
and such that um
yeah i don't have a concise answer to
when the right moment is uh but i'd say
it's a little bit similar to how i
started setting up this multi-select
component is realizing there's a
repeated pattern in your code and
wanting to abstract it out so yeah
then i'm really really glad to be here
today
[Applause]
all right folks that's a wrap for our
first
in person and virtual meetup in over two
years someone say thank you all the
people who came here and like brave both
the weather and the and uh hopefully
toward the end of the pandemic the
pandemic amazing video to be here uh you
know everyone
yet to be vaccinated enter the building
maxes are encouraged so folks feel free
to come out
remember
jobs go to the job postings channel of n
my hacker slack
eat your favorite pizza as soon as you
can
and remember the conference is next week
wednesday thursday friday it has
workshops and two days full of talks we
have a panel session of john crone uh
john kron i would say his name wrong
every time and i'm interviewing hillary
mason we have a bunch of happy hour at
the conference we have a whole bunch of
fun events going on it's gonna be a
really great time so get your tickets
next month's meetup will be announced
in the next two weeks give us some time
we'll announce it pretty soon uh i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna hit two it's gonna
be cause i just wanna make sure it's all
final before we announce it and then if
anyone wants to be a speaker message me
message nicole message joe get in touch
with us somehow let us know you want to
be a speaker sometimes we schedule three
weeks in advance sometimes we schedule
nine months in advance so it depends
when you get us so if you want to give a
talk let me know
and as always all these talks are going
to be available on our youtube channel
for the video and the slides will be up
at nyhakar.org in fact if you go to
nyhackguard.org you can find 13 years
worth of slides and probably about eight
years worth of videos so it's a really
really great resource and if you want
the videos from the conference that's
rstats.ai and click the videos button up
there lots of great options to find all
this great content so many times like
hey how do i do something i just go
check out one of these videos it's
really really great so again thank you
for everyone who joined us virtually
thank you everyone to join us in person
and i will see you all uh next week or
next month bye everybody